california is just days from announcing
it is dropping all of its mass
and social distancing requirements for
fully vaccinated people
but turning the page on the coronavirus
comes with risks example
two vaccinated passengers on a cruise
ship tested positive
for covid it comes as 52 percent of the
country has received at least
one dose of the cova 19 vaccine and 43
percent of adults in the u.s are now
fully
vaccinated michael george is here with
the latest michael good morning
good morning jeff as masks come off and
many places reopen
they're reminders that the world is
still in a pandemic and the signs of
risk
keep resurfacing aboard the celebrity
millennium two passengers tested
positive
causing a ship-wide safety check the
cruise company which requires proof of
vaccinations
told cbs news this demonstrates that our
rigorous health and safety protocols
work
the cdc recommends 95 percent of crew
and passengers be vaccinated
but onshore people are still getting
sick
variants are looming one of the things
that covet has proven it's really good
at curveballs
and so we hear about this new delta
variant that is now surging through the
uk
and beginning to come into the us the
good news about it is
when you're fully vaccinated you appear
to be fully protected against that
each vaccination has become a victory
this one
yesterday in new jersey was celebrated
also in san francisco this week with 80
percent of eligible residents
now vaccinated that's above the
president's 70 percent vaccinated july
4th goal
that many state governors are
championing that means we have
approximately 93 000
oregonians left to vaccinate to hit our
70 percent goal
lotteries in california beer in
minnesota
and to remind folks that not only the
beer is free
the vaccine is free wherever you take it
are part of the push
but vaccine hesitancy in oklahoma is not
helping
there has been an anti-vaccine
movement and it's actually quite strong
here in oklahoma
unfortunately oklahoma ranks near the
bottom
just 54 percent of adults have had at
least one dose
nationwide it's 64 percent we do
need to race against the risk of a
resurgence we need to get that number as
high as we can before the fall so we
don't have
a reemergence code and another concern
was raised yesterday new data shows
there have been at least
226 cases of heart inflammation in
people aged 30 and younger who received
a pfizer or moderna vaccine
the cdc will hold an emergency meeting
of advisors next week
to discuss the possibility of a new and
extremely rare side effect of covid
vaccines for young
people dana michael thank you